Benjamin's with me in Phoenix hi
Benjamin welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
how are you doing better than I deserve
what's up hey so I'm a 21 year old and
just trying to figure out if it's time
to move up in car I currently have a
Mitsubishi Galant Oh 3 was around 100k
miles on it I bought it for about 1400
just over a year ago but I've put in
about 2,000 for repairs and it breaks
down about every four months
it's actually in the shop right now as
well so I'm a junior in college
completely debt-free I have got about
3,000 right now set aside for the rest
of my schooling I the next year should
cost 4,500 including housing and food
and that'll be in my last year of
schooling I have a $1600 emergency fund
and another thousand set aside for my
next car that I was planning to get when
I graduate and I was just thinking if
right now would probably be a better
time to get it mm-hmm okay
what would the Mitsubishi bring if you
sold it today so Kelly Blue Book has
private sale at about 2,500 you think
you can get that for it I think I could
get either that or about 2,200 for it I
am with the Falcon and I did it with a
thousand added to it we're talking about
a 3,200 on our car give or take yes but
I've also got an extra thousand that I
haven't allocated allocated to college
or the car fun yet and it which are
surely an extraordinary college only
have three thousand are your 4500 for
college yes but the I won't have to pay
for that until August and I currently
work two jobs I have a position here on
campus that I get about 800 a month
months from and we'll be going up to
about 1200 over the summer and then my
other job is a delivery job for GrubHub
which is a food delivery service that I
make about 2,000 a month for good fine
and so what are you what are you
studying what are you studying
mechanical engineering mm-hmm okay and
you graduate when may 20 2015 20 months
okay no no I'm sorry yeah a little a
little over a year okay and and then I
and any student loans sorry you have any
student loans
I know student loans completely debt
free where you going to school Grand
Canyon University in Phoenix good for
you well done sir well done okay so
you've got a couple grand you can put
with it you're moving into a four
thousand dollar car okay yes I said
you're with the and then scrounging up
from some of my other savings accounts I
could do forty five hundred for the my
next car I mean I work to do like this
week I'm in nice fun here's the thing
okay
the Mitsubishi Galant an old one like
that is going to be an expensive car to
work on whatever you buy doesn't need to
be an expensive car to work on so even
if you got a great deal on it you don't
buy an old Mercedes it's going to be
very expensive to work on okay you buy a
plain Jane Ford Chevrolet Honda
something that's easy to work on
Toyota okay I was thinking Toyota yeah
something that's a reliable and B not
expensive to work on that everybody that
turns a wrench can work on it and you
got kind of you kind of got an expensive
car to work on there is the problem yeah
and so and the thing you can be sure of
in the $5,000 and under range you're
going to be working on it you're going
to be I mean you can get something more
reliable than the one you've got and but
you're going to be working on it so
that's thing one is get something that's
kind of a more generic in terms of like
again again a good Honda Accord a Toyota
Camry a Chevy a forward of some kind
something that you will pick up I don't
care something like that that's very
predictable and generic and they're
everywhere and it has absolutely no sex
appeal yeah all it is is transportation
that's thing one
thing to is it has absolutely no sex
appeal what you are looking for here is
not necessarily a pretty car you are
looking for a reliable car because
you're not going to drive this car but
about four or five ten months after you
graduate because you're going to be
making serious money as a mechanical
engineer coming out and you're gonna
have no debt and you have rocked it dude
you've done so good I'm so proud of you
and you're gonna be able to buy it in or
it's what you're gonna be able to buy a
ten or twelve thousand dollar car in 20
minutes and pay cash for it so this
isn't this this car has a two-year life
with you it's not you're not gonna live
with it
so if it's uglies like you have to give
it a name kind of a car but it is
mechanically sound okay an example would
be it has hail damage which you don't
get in Phoenix unless somebody imported
it okay not the hail but the hell
damaged car but that would be an example
if you had a hail damaged car that had
just 30,000 miles on it and it was a
Honda Accord and you've got a fabulous
deal on it because of that and then you
drive old pockmarked face car or
whatever you name the thing and with a
with great pride because it's going to
be very very reliable there's a lot of
life left under the hood but the hoods
dented or the paint is the ugly color or
whatever you are not this is not your
forever car you're not ever gonna have a
forever car but this is not a car you're
going to keep awhile it's not a car
you're gonna take great pride in this is
a wise purchase to get you through
because you've been very wise about
everything else you've done in this
equation the stuff you told me is way
beyond your years you're very impressive
well I grew up listening to your Dave
I'll take all the credit but not really
you're good man that's what I would do I
would buy it but you're looking for
something generic and cheap to work on
and something that has a lot of
mechanical life in it and if you have to
forego aesthetics beauty sex appeal in
order to get high mechanical value low
mileage in great shape mechanically I'll
take that that's the four thousand five
hundred dollar car I'm looking
for if I'm you folks that's how you
purchase a hoopty you buy it out of
grandmothers garage and mother passed
away and the kids are having an estate
sale that includes the old station wagon
and you can buy that sucker for 700
bucks and it has 20,000 miles on it and
it's a 1994 and it is literally the
truck tires are dry rotted because it's
been sitting in our garage you have to
put tires on it this is how you buy a
hoopty and you can get a lot of life out
of a hoop you're doing that now though I
want you to drive like that forever
no I'm not telling you that don't be
calling me up and tell me your junk cars
a Dave car your Dave cars when you're in
everyday millionaire and you drive
whatever you want but if you'll drive
like no one else later you can drive
like no one else Benjamin's driving like
no one else he's working like no one
else and he's going to school like no
one else that young man is a rock star
he's paying cash for school he's working
like a crazy man two jobs he's going to
school he's graduating on time he's got
a great field of study and it's all with
cash and he's 21 years old he just made
some of you 42 year old whiners look
pitiful he just kicked your butt you
look pitiful beside him you're whining
about you things you say you need you
don't need nothing you got everything
you need you want some stuff and I'm not
afraid to let you get some things you
want but some of you have had your once
eat your whole life up and they're piled
up in your closet and they're piled up
on your desk in the form of credit card
debts and that young guy right there man
he's got tiger by the tail the 2030
one-year-old version to him he may
already be a millionaire before he's 30
it's possible the way that kids thinking
unless he marries poorly if he marries
the princess he'll screw the whole thing
out but I don't think so I don't think
that's going to happen to you hey guys
this is how it works the Tsar works the
shortest distance between you and the
life you want
having up
all the money so that you can do the
things you want to do change your family
tree take care of your family
travel drive like no one else live in a
better home than you're in now the
shortest distance between that that's
not greed and it's not a prosperity
message the shortest distance is for you
to get rid of the freakin debt and stay
out of it and that's exactly what he was
planning how he's planning right there
all the way back at 21 years old god I
wish I'd have been half that smart